[موسيقى]
ونعم
الك حرام
[موسيقى]
عليهم وين بدنا نروح بعد هيك وين اطفالنا
وين اولادنا يروحوا والله حرام عليهم
يعملوا في الطور هيك ايش ذنبنا احنا ايش
ذنبنا يقول نا ايش ذنبنا هيك طورنا تروح
كلها يعني بالموت لما كنا
نجيبه حرام عليهم هيك دورنا اطلعوا دورنا
هيك ايش زنبنا احنا من وين بدنا نعمر مين
بده يعملنا مين ب سوي لنا هيك حرام عليهم
اطلعوا هيك بلملم اغراضنا صرنا بالشوارع
قاعدين بالشوارع بننام وين بدنا ننام بعد
هيك وين بدنا نروح وين قولوا لنا يا عرب
وين يا عرب حد ي حلنا يا عرب معي موتونا
موتوا اولادنا موتوا كل الدنيا والله حرام
عليكم ايش بدنا نسوي حسبي الله ونعم
الوكيل بنقول اكثر من هيك من يوم الحرب من
سبعه ع لما رموا علينا القذائف وتصوب ابوي
اخوي وامي تصاوب
وشرنا من دار لدار في الشوارع قعدنا وفي
المدارس قعدنا وهلق في المعسكر محاصرين
وقاعدين هينا بالله مش لاقينا واعي
لاولادنا كيف لقيتوا بيتكم هي بيتنا وين
هي بيتنا وهي بيت وه اطلع كيف البيوت
والله حرام والله الله ما قاله هيك يصير
فينا اه والله فرشنا بالشارع وحياتنا
بالشارع تدمرنا م مين المسؤول علينا في
هذا الاشي والاطفال ايش ذنب الاطفال
هدول مش لاقينا وعينا ولاق ننام اصلا
فيدور والله مزولين في الشوارع في دار هنا
مزولين وهنا مزولين وفي المدارس وحصنا
وهان وبصرو معي معيق الله حسبي الله ونعم
الوكيل بقول اكثر من
هيك اسماء نجم حياك الله ام
كريم والله اواع انا لقي مصاري ما معان
والله بصيح عشكل ما احنا ملقين لهم والله
الطحين قاعدين طحين طرب بضحكوا علينا فيه
يخشش مساعدات يخشش شي للناس والله حرام
عليهم والله ماحنا لاقين الاكل ولا لاقيين
حاجه منحل جينا لقينا دورنا مامنا هيك ايش
بدنا نسوي حسبي الله ونعم
[موسيقى]
الوكيل شوف ابو عي بعتنا
صور
[موسيقى]
ح
هنا ايضا تظهر ابراج المدينه السكنيه
الصريه في منطقه
الكرامه
الارض صابها بعض الضرر
جراء
الاجتياح تواز قوات الاحتلا
[موسيقى]
المنطقه انا ديمه
هنيه
الشيخ رضوان الشارعي الثالث شو بتقولي بعد
ما ش
ه حسبي الله ونعم الوكيل ايش هذا والله ما
خل ولا شي بغزه غزه دمروها منح منهم
اليهود انه خلوا هدور خلو مستقبل
الواحد حياه المدينه المصريه منيح منهم
انه خلوا هذا ه العمارات
الواقفه
l